so let's let's look at the sustainable
seafood case and tell us what are the
pieces of that and do they exist that
are that are they out there and deployed
do we have you know IOT in the seas
that's validating that the way these
things are coming what are what are that
ecosystem if you will of technology and
how much of those things are in place
and how much is almost there and how
much are further off can you give us
Accenture some of the turns I don't
think that's a hardware problem like I
think there are devices now that are
available off-the-shelf to be able to do
the kinds of stuff I mentioned there's a
company called smart catch that makes
these sensor net sensors actually then
they even have video cameras on them so
you can see the kind of fish that you
caught it's kind of crazy
um there are these sensors on buoys and
at ports and things like that to collect
that data that's real the blockchain
side of that picture is really simple
it's you know you stand up a network of
nodes and I mean this is what hyper
ledger is built this stuff is in
production now that ledger that chain is
not in production yet that's still being
developed Intel is one of the leads on
that but it they have gone to a number
of the different fish processors and and
some of the major fleet operators all of
whom are true what they're trying to
prevent are the renegade fishermen who
actually offload their caches to legit
fishermen in weird waters right who then
come back into port and try to offload
so I'd say probably the biggest
challenge will be getting a critical
mass of the participants in any market
place had enough layers in the chain
from beginning to end to start working
together so that they basically shame
abide by it by working well shame the
rest into joining that network and maybe
that even means if you're not eventually
if you're not part of that network you
can't sell your fish not only the Whole
Foods but maybe not even to any any
supply any retailer in the United States
right so I think I think the it's the
but there's a bootstrapping problem with
a lot of these names and and so and just
to look at it a little bit more closely
so so it's so it's starting with the the
Fisher level to the merchant level is
the end point along the way there are
transportation
eggs that are there there maybe the port
itself that needs to have some
infrastructure there and are you seeing
that or does it look like it would be
something online so it's like the Good
Housekeeping Seal that this is like
certified how does that I mean deep to
you and again this isn't obviously your
piece of it but I'm curious what you're
here because you're talking to I mean in
your role I think you are encountering
every piece of the ecosystem of folks
that are touching this stuff is it that
I would have a nap and I would be able
to see that this fish was and verify
that myself or that the merchant is
providing that certainty at that level
this is still predominantly a
business-to-business technology right
and and it should be the case that
they'll be eventually providers who act
as a kind of a portal for average
consumers to be able so that you know in
theory Whole Foods should be able to
provide you some sort of app that says
where did my fish come from that
surfaced the data back to that chain you
still have to trust that Whole Foods is
telling you the truth right so that you
know but it could be at some point that
that ledger becomes fully public and
there's multiple ways to get to it and
verify it an example of an application
I'd really like to see that looks more
like that would be voter registration
rolls so a lot of people talk about hey
should we use the blockchain to help
manage elections and I think it's a
terrible idea to cast votes using a
blockchain because it's really hard to
simultaneously preserve the integrity of
the election and the confidentiality of
voters while being able to audit it but
you could use a distributed ledger for
the voter registration side of it so
that everyone's looking at the same
database with regards to who's
registered to vote where and you could
use it at the tail end too which is what
what's the summary from each of the
different locations right
each of the different polling places and
enrolling rolling that up to kind of a
state level or a global kind of national
summary for how the vote went right and
in both those cases having the public be
able to see that ledger each individual
item right the entire spreadsheet so to
speak is essential to building trust and
confidence in the process and so for
that I would fight for that to be very
public for something like diamonds
you know the participants in that market
have already gone through this comp
like political balancing act of sharing
just enough information that they can
audit each other on where these diamonds
came from but not sharing things like
the prices they paid right and an other
metadata that could be used by investors
perhaps to short stocks of companies
that they think might not be doing well
right so there's I'm a very Pro open
data kind of guy and transparency got a
guy but for a lot of good reasons the
business communities are only willing to
share data if they can't if it means
they can't get access to other things
right and in the case of the diamond
industry there is a mandate from the
policy makers to clean up their act when
it came to blood diamonds and that sort
of thing and that kind of pressure is
essential in a lot of these chains I
think these chains are a way to finally
get extra things that economists
consider externalities in markets
finally reintegrated into the flow of
goods and commerce and you know whether
that's labor conditions or carbon credit
you know carbon load for example of the
different products flowing through or
you know other things correlating to the
sustainable development goals so that's
the idealist to me and that's kind of
why I'm involved in this and you've got
to have it create just enough economic
value a business value for the
businesses to pick it up and use it
because they won't do that
just endogenously they need some
business problem that they can solve at
the same time
[Music]